how's the pregnancy going
cool good question yeah why are you
trying to say good question what are
y'all trying to go viral for I'm just
curious
I can turn up like what's that I'm not
drinking so you're not drinking anymore
because of the baby
still down to throw the pause though
yeah you ain't drinking but you're
fighting
not that far along
how are you dealing with uh with the
pregnancy though that's like a big uh
there's a lot of [__] going on in your
body I'm sure
I feel bad about it the same
when are we getting the uh the
ultrasound so we know the baby sex or
you're gonna kind of just let it let it
ride and just be surprised when it
happens no I was we were filming a
season two of crazy in love so that's
going to be on there we're gonna do this
whole oh so that's a part of the new
season yeah shout out to the Zeus
Network yeah
so that's
that's the cage